did you ever well see I loved when I was
a kid making prank calls now you could
have because you're without doing that
much your voices are so similar you
could have gotten each other and like
you could call aside from looking alike
but I think when you know twins I dated
twins not you two I did not dat at the
same time much much T we wanted that to
happen but it never happened but you
didn't do that at school I imagine you
can do that as no I'm saying dating hoe
we wanted that to guys catch up catch up
on the pager we had one of our teachers
at school said cuz these twins looked
more alike than we did but they he was
saying how technically our children
would be related um as siblings because
they would look identical and and they
would have the same genetic code
confused because we were both talking
idal twins well they would be like half
right they would be like half siblings
what this teacher was trying to say is
that they would genetically look like
they were actually related because it
was twin parents Shar DNA but anyway to
go back to your story yes we pranked the
out of people all the time I would
I'm talking about even pranking each
other like if I was mad at I don't sound
like my brother but if I was if I was
mad at my brother it would be funny to
call into his workplace or to call the
person that he was dating and just say
something really up and then just
hang up the phone and wait for them to
get I so I would do that just to mess
with Drew if there was like a girl in
high school that was interested in him
yeah I would then not just on the phone
or anything I would literally dress in
his clothes we looked exactly the same
when actually when we were younger you
couldn't tell us part and I would go and
make a total ass out of myself in front
of her and then go away and then she
would ignore Drew why doesn't she like
me anymore and it's because so we would
we would do that kind of stuff cuz
that's the only benefits of having a
twin is to pull pranks on people and to
pin a murder on the twin exactly so
that's you know that's my out one day
have you you've done one out of two yeah
we'll leave you to guess which
one but I would just cuz I love prank I
love that you in order to prank had to
put on the same clothes like you really
think that were your clothes that
different that they would know I was a
jock so I yeah there's there there's
more of a relaxed he was a magician so
he wore like tight shiny shirts and gold
wor tails and you got have a top hat he
had a top hat bunny yes where did you
put your rabbit but you uh yeah you you
kind of the the easiest way to prank
people as a twin is when people are not
expecting you to be a twin so I remember
there were situations like Drew Drew
worked for an airline at one point he he
got hired there first and then he's like
oh this is so much fun you got to come
and do this and so when I got hired no
one he had worked with but for the year
prior no one knew he had a twin and so
all of a sudden I show up and it was
great I had a field day we flight
attendant we flight attend yeah flight
attendant did you ever work the same
flight oh yeah absolutely people thought
we were Air Marshals people would come
in they come in the front door and we
would plan this all out so they'd come
in the front door and I would be like
hello you know happy Tuesday nice to see
you go ahead and then Drew would be in
the middle of the plane and would say
the exact same thing for B and then
people would turn around but I would
step back into the gallery so they
couldn't see me and they just like or we
would go how the did the flight
attendant is flying from the front of
the
plane it was it was good it was uh we
also got a couple of our friends hired
and this was WestJet Airlines and uh
WestJet at the time was trying to be
different than and you know Air Canada
was the Canadian go-to and so they were
hiring taller people cuz there was there
was a height limit you weren't I think
with Air Canada you weren't allowed to
be over 6'2 or something and we're 6'4
so we wait wait wait so this is their
push toward diversity this is early days
diversity yes so we had us and all of
our friends we all like 6'4 and so
literally it was the best behaved
flights because everybody thought we
were a bunch of Air Marshals and they
were all just sitting there quietly and
we like would you like a drink no I'm
I'm fine I'm fine so super easy flights
yeah but being that tall on a flight is
probably as uncomfortable as it is
sitting where you're sitting right now
i' I've hit some turbulence where I
actually hit the ceiling of the plane I
would imagine you start on the ceiling I
was going to say you're only an inch
below the ceiling so it hurt less than
if I flew all the way up
yeah